you know I like chips hold on hold on
hold on I don't want to start yet I got
to get comfy okay we at this
new new carpet you know I want to get
comfy yeah what does that the dogs
breathe actually let's let them really
breathe here oh wow oh wow oh wow oh my
God yep that's good
yeah no I'm sure it is oh that's good
I'm so sure it is this carpet's awesome
is it you can really feel yeah yeah it's
nice all you want to get started yeah
cool
yeah Sor I had a long I had a long drive
to the launch pad you know yeah so it's
nice to really just like yeah let it out
yeah kick back and kind
of such a nice texture on this carpet I
took Molly on the way
here is that all Molly is it's just
feeling like you're Barefoot on a nice
carpet the rest of the episode that's
that's disgusting look at my [__]
disgusting I've seen that I've seen no
I've seen that foot enough in my life
dud star that nail for the rest of the
episode right I've seen enough of that
nail for my entire life doesn't this
suck it's back how did it get
back I'm not a [__] doctor I thought
you took pills for it I did and this one
has
remained it's you know it's remained he
I believe it I know you're not to look
at it look at it's a it's a perfect foot
listen man I've seen him before you're
really not going to look at my foot all
right there you go it's looking a lot
better it is looking a lot better but
this one you you don't have to look at
that one yeah yeah I don't blame you
yeah I play my new this is new guys of
the week oh new new couple of the week
okay oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh you saw
this yeah I left I left this one alone
for a minute why oh you you've seen this
old I've Dove deep on uh on on this one
right here why'd you leave it alone like
this is perfect for us yeah I know I
just I don't know okay should we not
watch it no we can we could watch it run
it
yeah yeah now this
[Music]
um is a river I keep in the flow you
shaking you shiver I'm warming you cold
I'm holding your soul your aura is
glowing is gold Blossom like Floral
potent you notice but notice how much
that we've grown Oma the vibe on the
throne nothing is own everything borrow
can't promise tomorrow be honest you're
whole you're whole you're
whole that that's what that's what the
guy in the Reddit said when the college
guy was finishing your whole your whole
your
whole damn you're
[Laughter]
whole
no he's going to finish in your hole I
didn't even realize that was a song yeah
I literally just saw the thumbnail I was
like this is awesome oh no yeah that's
this is [__] awesome yeah no I've
I've done a deep
dive what else what else have you found
there's not much she's just kind of
promoting the same three
singles do people listen to her or she
got a lot of
followers I don't know I don't know if
they watch this [__] on mute or I just
think it's funny to like shrooms that
much yeah like doing a huc or like doing
like a you know psychedelic drug and
then making it your entire yeah image
and brand and [__] yeah like trying to
look like what you saw yeah yeah yeah
exactly it's really uh it's a commitment
it really is man this not I don't know
this is why I left it alone CU what can
you really say without being mean yeah
true kind of just requires you to be
mean so you know I like the I like the
song I like their verses yeah yeah I
thought it was great I think we should
do rap about spirituality no we should
do a song like that but about you know
cocaine or something oh got it got it
right yeah they're CU they're trying to
we should do one but um about meth yeah
that be that' be the BPM is like like
180 rapping really fast yeah 180 double
time oh my God yeah and the and it's
like little bit of no no it it should be
it shouldn't feel fluid at all feel like
a Detroit rap song but like on steroids
okay I walk down the street I punch a
wall I stole a brick you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm doing quests yeah
yeah yeah that's a good idea that just
that equivalent yeah I also think it's
funny to uh I don't
know I don't know what what this kind of
like a catchall but I just think it's
funny to write 16 bars about God or like
existential stuff yeah I don't know why
it just is funny to me yeah it is kind
of funny to be like I'm about to lock
in I see you I don't know I on my run I
was uh like probably three miles into it
and I blacked out and I saw
them the heat got imagine imagine
tripping and that's what you see yeah
them too imagine like someone you're
tripping and someone's like oh I got the
perfect song for
you they're just like sit down watch
this better acid little bit of sh like
what is
this what is this no no it gets really
good is that tree talking or was it you
I don't know yeah this is making me feel
really weird man I think my trip's
turning around no no keep watching his
verse it gets
better why did he record his on a like a
you know like like I like Apple
headphones yeah right
head yeah his
the mix on that was pretty bad pretty
horrible I think we should I think we
should slow this down and like trip it
out little bit of acid little bit of and
put like Devil laughs in the
back yeah some people do listen to this
stuff high so that would just by the way
the police are
coming you think someone is listening to
this it's on acid or mushrooms right now
I don't think so I think come on that'
be probably odds are one person
that'd be a shrooms Yes actually yes
people shrooms for sure like maybe a
micro you know Bo hello police are
here it's the
police that just reminds me when SAA set
up a a notification on my stream of a
door knocking he just did it without
telling me that [__]
bro I sitting there I'm
like I come on man come on man I didn't
believe that [__] come on that's really
fun
that and then everyone they got me the
first time spider on the wall oh really
oh dude I felt so dumb what wait what's
the like they just said that in the chat
spider on your wall yeah okay yeah and I
went
spider and then they're like [__]
loser I can't believe he literally
turned around this guy's scared of
spiders which I am I'm fine admitting
that fully am scared of spiders yeah I
don't know if you want to keep going
down the um the shroom hole oh no
oh yeah yeah I was going to say I saw
okay so 3 miles into my run yeah and I
ran by a bus stop and this dude had
gotten off the bus and was walking to
work and just fully had pissed his pants
sweet it was awesome probably 7:45 a.m.
he just had piss completely drenched
down his pants and he looked at me and
just nodded like
that like I was like where what is your
plan dude yeah he said I'm going to work
what are you going to do when you get
there we'll see you think he's got extra
pants in his backpack you think maybe
he's just trying to get fired yeah
maybe I kind of thought maybe I was like
you know I was running I was doing a
back story in my head making up
something crazy like he got [__] up
you know and was like oh [__] my shift
starts oh and like you know maybe it was
like so [__] up he passed out on the
bus that's probably it woke up and just
had piss all the way down probably it
hadn't even noticed it yet maybe shown
up to the job site nods at me like
wonder if if that guy knew I was
drunk and then no dude he's so drunk you
forgot he pissed yeah true and he's like
man people in this town are actually
kind of nice La gets a bad rap yeah
yeah that's the guy who's shown up to
build the
[Laughter]
freeway